energy price cap set by off gem sets a
maximum for unit prices and standing
charges for gas and electricity and then
expresses that number as an annual cost
for a typical household family of four
and this is what that number looks like
over time we go back to the late 2010s
and into the 2020s around a thousand
pounds a year when it got to 1200 pounds
after covert we thought that was a lot
of money but look what happened after
the invasion of Ukraine by Russia the
effect on gas markets the price cap the
real cost of supplying energy to have
soared above four thousand pounds at one
point today we've had the figure set for
July back down to a more affordable
figure 2 000 pounds a year that's uh for
typical use for families still double
what we were paying earlier but a great
delivery for around 400 pounds worth of
savings for families that's because for
most of the period when prices were
really high government was subsidizing
our energy use with the energy price
guarantee set at 2 500 pounds here we
were paying this portion of the bills
the church was picking up the area in
light blue here that's the real cost of
energy now that bill has run to 94
billion pounds so far so little wonder
that Jeremy Hunt when Sky News spoke to
him a little earlier was relieved
well I think we've shown in the past
that where there are acute pressures
that people face unexpectedly we want to
do everything we can to help families I
don't want to predict today what might
happen to Energy prices at the moment
we're not expecting to see those kinds
of increases but of course we don't know
that and all I can say is that I think
I've demonstrated in the Autumn
statement and the spring budget where I
extended the energy price guarantee for
another three months funded in part by a
winful tax on the oil companies that we
are willing to do what it takes
let's remind ourselves where these
numbers come from they're based on
wholesale gas market prices again look
back end of the 2010s gas below 50p a
firmed and these huge spikes when the
war is underway and Russian gas
effectively went out of the European
Energy Mix pushing up prices they're now
below 70 Pence a therm for the first
time since 2021 and off gem uses these
prices because companies buy their
energy in advance it uses these prices
to work out the future reasonable cost
and fair cost to Consumers so what is
going to happen next 2074 pounds the cap
for July set today it's going to be
around that number in October these are
according to forecasts and into the
start of next year that's January 2024
so some stability for consumers but
remember that is still double these
numbers back here this is the long term
average what we're used to paying so two
thousand pounds is already enough to
push millions of people into fuel
poverty that's a mainstream experience
now the cost of living squeeze remains
even though these prices have come down